make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
okay uh so before we start this video
two things one
for those of you guys who are curious
about the selling of rob core rings that
was not a one-off i'm gonna sell them
again but i'm gonna i'm gonna do it
again i'm not gonna leave you guys just
once
two those rings sold out in two hours
now i have not found a way on
etsy to show that the rings were sold
out right as soon as a single ring type
show
sold out then it was like etsy
automatically delisted it right so
that's why some of you guys went to the
store and you didn't see anything there
because they were all sold out right but
in two hours they were all gone for
those of you guys who did buy rob core
rings you should be able to go onto etsy
and you should see the status of your
order
uh they should all be on their way the
only exception is we got an order from a
guy in norway and we had a little bit of
a complication it was on our end it was
not anything you did wrong uh but we
fixed it and everything's all sorted out
so
uh we will order more rob core rings and
we will send out more rob core rings and
i will place more up for sale so keep
your ears open
and i will let you guys know when you
can buy them so uh anyway
on to the video what's going on guys
this
is rob and we are picking up with the
conclusion
of x of sores i hope you guys had a
great thanksgiving week i know i did
i definitely needed that break i
absolutely needed that break uh
i was going nuts just i think we've been
probably doing this non-stop for about
two years
without really taking a break uh so i
needed one
but uh but we are picking back up with
the conclusion of uh of x of swords
right we're wrapping this whole thing up
and initially i thought about doing each
of these individuals
separately but i think at this point we
can just kind of do all the videos
together and just sort of call it a day
i do want to touch on the hellions
because we're going to kind of skip over
this the hellions was a totally
unnecessary story i'm not really sure
why it was included in this in the first
place the only real takeaway those guys
who remember the only real thing going
on with the hellions is that their goal
was to get into otherworld and steal the
swords of morocco so they couldn't even
compete in the first place which would
basically seem to nullify the entire
tournament now as we saw
not all the fights were being done with
swords really only those who needed
swords would be disqualified but then
saturn probably would have changed
things what ended up happening with the
hellions however is that it was revealed
that sinister simply wanted to just
steal genes of mutants that existed out
there
and once the other hellions found out
sinister managed to achieve his goal to
a degree
and then came back to uh the curcumin
gate back into the main
marvel universe so to speak and then
pretty much killed all the hellions and
that was basically it right so
there's a little bit going on there but
not a whole lot certainly nothing that
works
you know that warrants us covering the
entirety of the story but what's really
important here is we pick up with the
next part of the tournament which takes
place in
cable and this is done by virtue of
cable having to face off against bay now
of course bay
is the wife of doug ramsey right she's
the wife of cipher and so cable's kind
of watching all this
or i guess he's really kind of engaging
in this knowing that he's probably gonna
have to kill the wife of doug
ramsey and in that moment of hesitation
bae gets the upper hand now
here's the big difference because cable
says things like you know if i had been
who i was before then this probably
never would have been a problem in the
first place and that's true
one of the things those guys aren't
really familiar here and i've heard
people ask this why is cable so young
marvel introduced a retcon by basically
having cable's younger self kill his
older self
and then take his place as kind of like
the new cable it was a way for marvel to
kind of reinvigorate the character a
little bit i kind of feel like it was
unnecessary the older cable had a lot of
great storytelling going on and i think
in situations you know he would have
been a lot more interesting useful
and would have made the stories a lot
more intriguing but such as it is we
ended up getting younger cable instead
now the problem with younger cable is
he's not quite battle hardened yet not
in the same way that his older self is
and he's right when he says if this was
his older self he would have killed me
like that right it would have just been
over like he would have just killed her
in an instant and would have been like
cool like we get the point
done and he would have like watched doug
ramsey cry and he probably would have
comforted him and said hey man i'm sorry
but like you know
the entire kingdom of krakowa and the
entire like our entire earth
is more important than your wife right
so with that being the case with bae
getting the upper hand
uh with cable kind of hesitating for a
moment vade basically topples him she
breaks his arm and then she goes for the
killing blow
and doug jumps in and asks her to stop
right he says like stop like you
basically won
uh this was supposed to be finished
right and saturday had kind of declared
this was going to be a battle to the
death but it was going to be a fight to
the actual death itself but
then she kind of kind of relinquishes
here and says but some deaths are of the
spirit
right so in the end i award the point to
oracle kokoa is now down
basically it's 18 to six right they're
down by 12 points this is a pretty huge
number to have to catch up now from
there
you end up picking up with cable
contacting jean grey and cyclops
directly which is something that he's
not really supposed to be doing right
using his telepathy
and managing to reach to them but the
fact that he was able to do this to
essentially use his telepathic powers to
reach across
dimensional barriers and contact gene
and cyclops that's a huge thing right
this is really more of an act of
desperation
but for people who create like respect
threads right like the power of the
telepathy of
of uh the power of like cable's
telepathy or like jean grace telepathy
or something like that this is one of
those examples they will use right
they'll just say like was able to use
this telepathy across dimensional
barriers right or something along those
lines right that's where this kind of
stuff comes from but the reality of this
is cable looks at the situation and says
it's dire and we're probably going to
lose right like we're down 18 to six
the deck basically seems to be stacked
against us like she wants us to lose i'm
not really sure why you know i'm not
really sure what's going on here i'm
going to stay here and fight as much as
i can
but like tell esme right of the
stepbrooker coups the kind of girlfriend
of cable tell her i love her right i
mean that's kind of where this
is now saturning steps in and cuts off
his connection and that's when cyclops
and gene are like okay
we need to do something now we'll get
back to them here in a second what we're
gonna do here is we're gonna focus on
gorgon right he's the next fight now
gorgon
is one of these guys and the reason why
he wears a bandana around his head
is that if he takes it off and he looks
at you you'll turn to stone but he's
being made to fight off a face off
against white sword
but facing off against white sword is
not just fighting him it's fighting his
100 soldiers and so he says
like you'll fight me after you fight all
of them and so he says like once you get
through all 100 of these guys then we'll
battle
and so he says number one right this
first guy comes running in
gets like gets his head chopped off in
an instant then it's two and three those
guys get taken down then it's four
five and six right those guys get turned
to stone and one of them manages to make
it through and gouge out the eyes of
gordon so his primary power is basically
gone here and so now he's basically just
fighting using his own prodigious
martial arts skill but then it's
now you have to fight all the rest of
the other ones right you have to fight
seemingly all of them and so what ends
up happening is
that gorgon actually takes out something
like 13
of of like the white swords champions
which moves the number up right so it
actually gives them a lead right because
each one of these individuals that he
kills counts as a point so it kind of
seems like saturn names more or less
balancing the numbers and so now
cocoa is ahead 19 to 8. and that's when
the horseman step in and say
end this right because if he kills all
100 of your soldiers it's going to move
them up
they're going to be 106 to 18. they're
going to crush us
right like there's not going to be any
chance for us to win like the tournament
will basically be over
right i mean there's not enough you know
not enough opponents for us to face off
against to finish this right to come out
on top now so that's when white sword
steps in
and says okay fine then the battle will
be between the two of us
and it's one of these things where
gorgon knows he's not going to win
right like he knows he cannot come out
on top here there's no possible way for
that to happen and the white sword says
i'm going to kill you
and then i will bring you into my bring
you into my army and the response of
organ is not a chance right i walk my
own path whatever happens to me after
this whatever death awaits me whatever
comes next in this afterlife
it will not be as one of your henchmen
right and that's when uh when white
swords like okay fine if you don't want
to be then you don't have to be right
and then just punches the sword through
his chest
and basically kills him now there's two
cool things that come out of this
the first is apocalypse kind of
commenting and saying this is how a
mutant dies
if you're going to die you die on your
own terms you die and saying i'm not
going to be a subject to anybody else
right you die with what you perceive to
be your own honor the other thing that
comes out of this is that gorgon was
i wouldn't necessarily say an essential
member of the x-men roster but somebody
who probably could do with a bit of
revamping and the reason why is because
gorgon's never really had
major roles in marvel for quite some
time this is kind of an exciting moment
because it could be one of these things
where marvel just never chooses to bring
him back right hickman just kind of
writes him out
and he's gone or it could be they bring
him back and he's totally changed
because remember he died here in other
world which means if they resurrect him
he'll come back in any number of
different versions of himself from
across
the multiverse we don't know which
version it'll be so he could come back
with with better powers he could come
back weaker he could come back as just
some old sage wise man who never fights
he could come back in a wide array of
different forms but with
gorgon having been destroyed right now
the score is currently even orocco 19
krakow at 19. and i need you to keep
that in mind
hold that in in your mind as long as you
can
because this will become important
because this leads into the final battle
between apocalypse and his wife
who's donning the helmet of annihilation
one of the things that happens here is
an apocalypse challenges his wife to
face him off
as herself right to basically not use
the the power of annihilation or any of
that stuff to
really just kind of husband and wife
dueling each other but the other thing
that comes out of this is really more
with uh with jean grey and cyclops that
with the message they receive from cable
and the fact that things seem so dire
they go to the quiet council right and
they say like
we need to go do this like we need to go
rescue our son and the quiet castle's in
a in a bit of a predicament right
because
the biggest issue they face is that when
they ask cyclops what is it you intend
to do
cyclops response is twofold one i'm
gonna assemble a strike team this strike
team is it's gonna be a smash and grab
job right we're just gonna break into
the end of the world we're gonna pass in
there we're gonna grab our x-men
and we're gonna come back we need you to
hold the gate open
until we do now the issue with with the
quiet council is but what if you die
over there right if you die over there
there'd be no way for us to know
right because saturnine is cut off any
telepathic communications to that realm
so it's not like we can maintain a
telepathic lifeline
and know whether or not you survived and
say oh my god cyclops and gene and all
the x-men are dead all right close the
portal so they so nobody can get in they
just kind of have to wait and see
but if they die over there and there's
no way of knowing they died they could
potentially just be holding the portal
open for an invasion that they didn't
know was coming they could literally sew
their own end the other part of this is
that jean grey and cyclops are part of
the quiet council and so it'd basically
be taking away from
from their number now anybody who's
familiar with governmental positions
knows that usually individuals who hold
positions of government are not afforded
the opportunity of putting their life on
the line
leaders don't have that luxury right
because somebody has to govern it's the
responsibility you take on
and so what this means is that while
cyclops and gene are simply just going
to go right it's one of these things
where it's like we're gonna find a way
to leave so you're gonna have to like
lock us up or something then in turn the
quiet council now that they're met with
the
the idea that uh that like nightcrawler
wants to go their concern is okay
then what do we do now right what do we
do in this instance where the quiet
council could potentially lose
three or four of their number do we
suddenly just hope they come back in one
piece do we ensure the governing body
can function the way that it's supposed
to because remember
everybody here has a role to play so the
government has to continue on and so in
order to basically satisfy this need to
answer this question
a vote is given and the vote is is given
in two forms the first vote is
if you guys pass through that gate and
you die and there's no way for us to
know that you die
and we could be holding the gate open
for enemies then that means we have to
close the gate right we can't take the
chance that if you perish there and we
don't know that we allow all the enemies
to come flooding in right any chance
that we have of closing the gate will be
gone at that point and so what they say
is you know the first vote is
do we close the gate after the forces of
the strike team jean grey cyclops after
they all pass through
the answer is yes right we close the
gate the second concern is
what do we do about you guys leaving the
quiet council and potentially dying so
do we just kind of hope that you guys
make it back in one piece do we put the
entire government on hold
in order to you know in order to find
out whether you made it back never
knowing how long
it could take you to get back that if
something went wrong and you guys were
stuck there for decades and decades or
you guys just
grew old there and died because you
could never find a way back do we just
kind of
allow the quiet council to function in
its own way without you guys there
or do we fill your seats and when they
vote the answer is
if you go you lose your spot right we're
going to replace you with somebody else
but at the end of the day
gene and cyclops don't care their stance
is we don't care like we are going right
we're gonna go with this
you know apocalypse is already there
right it may very well be that he might
perish that there's individuals who are
out there that are supposed to be on the
council that could very well die
and so because of that you know they've
already lost so many of their number
they effectively vote
if jean grey and cyclops pass through
this gate and they take this strike team
and they go to otherworld for this
mission then they give up their position
on the quiet council
and jean grey and cyclops say we're okay
with that and they leave right they
basically walk away because it's one of
these things where they say if if the
quiet council is the government of
krakowa then the x-men are its heroes
and of what use are heroes who refuse to
fight
my allegiance is to the mutant
population my allegiance is to the
people and if we as the quiet council
are going to sit and just
rest on our laurels effectively you know
and just kind of not really do anything
in the face of such dire straits then of
what use
are we right and so cyclops and gene
basically leave and where you would
expect some measure of condemnation
from the quiet council instead it's
really magneto in sight and
and xavier who were just like that's
exactly how we raised you that's exactly
what you what we're supposed to do
and it's one of these things where we we
can kind of assume a lot of the reason
why some of these folks don't leave
could very well be tied to like mora
mccarter and the idea that like there's
this kind of greater game that was
established during the house and powers
of x
and the sense that like if they perish
everything would come to an end
it really seems to point to the idea
that jean grey and cyclops are not
really that essential to the future
survival of the x-men either that
or this is something that has to happen
right but regardless of the situation
they basically pass through and they go
into into other world itself and so
picking back up with apocalypse and his
wife
things are interesting here this is kind
of cool it's this really really amazing
moment
where the wife of apocalypse gets the
upper hand right genesis gets the upper
hand on him and
and like destroys his sword and says
okay like i give you one last kiss and
then i will hear your surrender and
welcome you back to your rightful place
by my side and then she like when she
destroys the sword she asks like will
you yield apocalypse here's the thing to
understand about apocalypse
right always outnumbered never outgunned
right apocalypse is not a guy
who falls easily right this is not a man
who yields
and that's exactly that's exactly what
he says man jonathan hickman jonathan
jonathan hickman jonathan jonathan
hickman man
man it's it's man it's it's it's so it's
like it's like one of the coolest
moments because apocalypse is like
i will not yield not to fear not to
doubt and not to love where genesis
thought she had the upper hand
and four moves it's and then she's done
right that's the end of genesis like
literally like just
swipes right through and that's that you
know like like and it's and it's nuts
because that's the thing man apocalypse
man is bad people
ma'am man she's sleeping on apocalypse
son like that's exactly what it is
and that's what makes it so crazy is
because with her basically being
defeated apocalypse is like i don't want
this right he looks to saturday and he's
like i don't want this right i don't
want to kill my own wife i'm not in
favor of this now keep in mind
the score is still 19 to 19. whoever
wins this
wins the contest and so with that
saturnine is like i don't really care
what it is that you want right like the
tournament must go on you
must slay your wife or be slayed by your
wife for victor to be determined here
but in this moment when apocalypse and
saturnine are having this conversation
then suddenly like genesis puts on the
helmet of annihilation
completely heals herself and is just
like nothing is settled right
like i annihilation am now in total
control here nothing is settled right
like
this will go on and we will fight now
when that happens
right like when she dons a helmet of
annihilation she calls in
everyone like literally all the forces
of ammoth
just come pouring into other world at
this point it's just like man the hell
with the tournament son
like we're just gonna do this right now
like that's exactly what this is
right now the the different little fairy
people whatever they are the fish folk
of uh like the forces of of saturnine
right here little assistance aids
whatever they are
they immediately run and grab like the
little uh like these this this kind of
box right that contains all these little
puzzle pieces more or less and the idea
is that when saturnine puts this
together it will
effectively give her an answer on what
her next move needs to be on what it is
she that she needs to do in this but
without you know beyond saturnine what's
going on right now
is all hell is breaking loose son like
all these forces of ammoth are pouring
in here and you've got like
six x-men and captain britain basically
facing off against them all doing
everything they can
now where where amith goes for the
killing blow against apocalypse and
seemingly he's just gonna let it happen
right like out of nowhere she's struck
by lightning right
out of nowhere she's struck by lightning
enters storm right storm's like okay so
she's only gonna be delayed for so long
right like she's only gonna be delayed
for so long
like we've got our armies routed we have
to get out of here right like we have to
leave and the responsible apocalypse is
like not a chance man like
no way we're like there's no way i'm
leaving my wife behind but at this point
it's not even the stance of of
apocalypse and what he wants it's like
like run run run away
live to fight another day right like we
can get out of here we can get back to
gracoa yes i guess i mean the score is
currently tied we can
figure this out later right but like for
right now we need reinforcements or
numbers or something while that's going
on
bae actually ends up abandoning the
forces of a rocco grabs doug
doug ramsey and just runs right just
like takes off running right it's just
like okay so like she snatches up her
husband right because you know
she's like hey you know i need to make a
man out of you before before we're done
so she snatches them up they just go
running and so all the x-men what's left
of these guys are basically just
fighting to the point of exhaustion
they're just fighting like to this
moment to this point of exhaustion and
there's not a whole lot that they can do
here it's just like like at this point
you've got what you've got
captain britain you've got wolverine
you've got apocalypse you got storm and
you got magic and that's it against this
virtually endless horde
of all these guys well then out of
nowhere here comes jubilee right here
comes jubilee coming in with like all
these fairy folk right because she was
just kind of hanging out with him for a
little while i guess it's by no means
like a like a turn like
it's not like it's like the battle is
turned right i mean it's jubilee she
creates fireworks right she's like you
know
she creates fireworks right there's
really nothing going on there but at the
very least their numbers are temporarily
bolstered and it does give them a chance
to kind of survive this experience
now what you also end up having is doug
ramsey talking to bae and saying look
like basically i love you right i mean
it's more or less what he says right
this is declaration of love like i
absolutely love you but we cannot stay
here right
we can't just run away from my friends
we have to go back
we have to help them survive like we
have to make sure that they live through
all this right we have to find a way to
end this tournament i can't just leave
them alone and so one of the things
he kind of asked her he's like you don't
have to stay here right you don't have
to stay
with with morocco you can come back when
this is all said and done
you can come back to krakowa and you can
live among us right you can live at my
place like we're married right so i mean
you know it's
it'll take a little bit of decorating i
mean it's a bachelor pad you know it's a
bachelors we've had until like a day ago
when we got married you know and
happened out of nowhere and i wasn't
really expecting it but you know i mean
surprises happen in this game of life
you know
i don't know what to tell you so it's
it's kind of a
it's kind of a cool little thing but
like basically of course bae ends up
traveling back you know and
so the forces are marshalled a little
bit larger but still there's not much
they can do here the funny thing about
that is that when all this begins to
happen
as all this is taking place you know
annihilation you know basically genesis
you know it's more or less possessed by
annihilation now it's like it's
like we won right like we basically won
here this not necessarily formal because
i haven't killed apocalypse but i'm
going to but i'm going to destroy this
guy
well then from there we switch over to
saturnine and as saturnine is assembling
this this puzzle piece that's when she
can she begins to realize oh my god
right she like she has to reassemble the
captain britain court more so than that
this this kind of puzzle that seems to
have existed before before she ever took
over was you know it's a little
ambiguous it all seems to point to the
idea of like the definitive
captain britain and the definitive
captain britain is betsy braddock right
like the fates have more or less
determined it's betsy bright now when i
say the fates
i don't mean some individual out there
who put this you know box of
of pieces here and then said okay you
know now saturday and you're in for
surprise when you find out who the
person is supposed to be
you know it's just one of these things
where it looks like it's out of her
control that's one of the things about
otherworld is it's very very ambiguous
right there's a lot of talk about the
fates and and how things could unfold
and you know how it could end and
whether or not things would turn out the
way that you hoped it to
it it's one of those things a little
ambiguous but the big takeaway from all
this
is the captain britain core completely
gets reformed by saturnine right she
reforms the entire core
and the entire court comes responding
right they they come pouring in right
they all come flying in
and it's like okay like our numbers are
bolstered like we have a chance the fact
that the captain britain court is
reformed it's pretty cool right we
haven't seen them since the events of
the incursions when they were all killed
by the map makers and the beyonders
right so this is the first time that
we're seeing the captain written core
fully reassembled
now for for the forces of annihilation
as she continues fighting and as a
captain britain corps comes showing up
they're not really putting up a huge
fight right there's not really a whole
lot doing here
uh and they're actually getting taken
out quite readily but what she says in
response to all this
is like they summon an army summon one
of our own and she talks to like war
right she's like summoned one of our own
so they summon
all these just helius looking creeps all
these just terrible looking monsters
from the world of
like literally from from like
annihilations realm someone like all
these different huge
monstrous beasts and things like that
like it's getting kind of
crazy right it's getting absolutely
bonkers and it's one of these things
where you end up having cyclops and gene
who chime into magic now here's the
here's the thing that happens man here's
the thing that here's the thing that
happened
everything just happens man so she hits
up hit some cyclops and jean here let me
show you something like cyclops and gene
hit up magic and they say okay
like you need to open a portal for us
right like we have our forces here you
need to open a portal and they're like
she's like okay like i was wondering how
long it would take for you guys to get
here right so
slams are stored into the ground opens a
portal and when it when she does
it brings in the entire sword space
station right this whole sword space
station when it opens up
everybody comes pouring out right so
you've got wind pool you've got dupe you
got gambit
right you've got you got all kinds of
people here you got quentin choir so
you've got like this huge mishmash of
like all these omega level mutants
and all that stuff like it's it's like
almost the entire forces of krakowa like
everybody who's currently an x-men comes
pouring out into this thing
and all hell breaks loose man let me
tell you something
let me tell you i'm jonathan hickman
jonathan jonathan
jonathan hickman man man it's man it's
it's man
man they were not prepared do the forces
of ammoth just just just like the
dude they it is an absolute massacre
right like it's an absolute bloodbath so
they start summoning even more of their
monsters right like even more of their
absolute monsters they're like she's
like summon it all
summon everything right bring everything
in here that you possibly can so all
these monsters start pouring in here
right like all these things
just start jumping in here the x-men are
all like fighting for the like
like fighting for their lives man like
it's it's it's absolutely bonkers and so
from there like like you have cable
who's kind of watching all this unfold
and he's just like he's like dude it
doesn't look like there's really a way
for us to win
and saturday is kind of talking to him
and she's like what card were you dealt
and he was like the fool and she's like
only a fool would really look at this
sword in belize that's all he's really
holding now
remember back when when donovan i'm
sorry when exit swords was going on
remember back when they were in the
sword space station and the whole sword
space station was taken over
by those crazy looking monsters right
those crazy looking monsters that only
desired death and destruction right you
guys remember that
and they managed to push them all back
through that portal and lock them away
in the realm of death
what ends up happening is cable's just
like oh my god right like i totally
forgot about that this is why jonathan
hickman does this stuff because they've
got an army
of forces that are just in the in the
thousands and thousands and thousands
that seemingly match the forces of a
rock code right or at least that seems
to be the case right that like maps that
huge army the forces of ameth like it's
just
waiting in the wings all they have to do
is just unleash it right and so like
cables like get me to the
give me to the ship right give me to the
sword ship giving to that device where
all we have to do is unlock it they're
like okay so as soon as they get in
there and they literally unlock that
door
all those forces come pouring in like
hell right like ileana rasputin makes a
portal so they all go flying into that
portal and they show up into this realm
and just start killing everything they
find right i mean if
if anything it's like lord of the rings
you guys remember like that that army of
the dead guys the ghost or whatever it
is like as soon as they show up like the
whole battle just turns right
that's exactly what happens there's this
amazing moment right where like one of
these these monster things are like
we've suffered in a dead realm for far
too long
picked its bones examined it fully now
we seek a heartier meal and like in
ammoth right annihilation right like
this this chick the the helmet chick
with the wife of apocalypse she's like
you want the full measure of a world
then come creature
taste my metal and feast on ammon and
like just annihilates this guy right
like i love the way that jonathan
hickman does like these one-liners like
they're just so ridiculously cool and so
like from there
like where she goes to make this other
statement apocalypse grabs her right
it's like tackles her down to the ground
and rips the helmet off her face right
like rips rips
the helmet of ammoth off the face of
genesis and remember the helmet of
ammoth has its own
its own mind right it does its own thing
you know anybody who wears the helmet is
possessed by the helmet and so
apocalypse puts the helmet on
everybody stops right everybody stops
and just like dude holy cow is this
really going to happen right now this
apocalypse going to put the helmet on an
apocalypse grabs it and
sits it on his head and like and and and
literally he's just like
i am remade right i am apocalypse you
know i am totally remade
and and annihilation tried like emma
tries to take over
apocalypse right like annihilation tries
to take over apocalypse and like and
initially it seems to be successful but
then like apocalypse takes over control
right he takes over control of the
helmet and it's just like
no like i am apocalypse i'm not some
servant to some arbitrary
object that exists out there that some
demon entities in possession of right
like when you step into the realm of
apocalypse's sphere of influence
you fall to the influence of apocalypse
right i will not be controlled by
anybody and just totally dominates the
helmet
now while all that's happening and the
way in which we know that everything is
going to turn is iska
turns against the forces of a rocko and
that's when they realize we're not going
to win right like literally her power is
to always win so as soon as she turn
codes then it's like okay then we've
basically lost here
and that's when apocalypse steps to
saturnine and says can you hear me and
she says yes i can hear you and i can
see you then he says
then fine i as as a host of annihilation
and the leader of the forces of of the
oracle army
i surrender and just gives up and that
gives the win to krakowa right kakoa
wins dude it's amazing man it's just
like dude that's so that's such a
ridiculously cool idea and then saturn
he's like cool
done let's do this right so she goes
flying in with with the shogo dragon
right who's dragonfire remember has the
ability to melt realms
and just like literally punches a hole
in this fabric of space
which rips through all the forces of
them of ameth right like it rips them
all through and even those those weird
demonic looking force entity guys right
like so so though they're all more or
less out of the way the demand the weird
guys in the other dimension
they're all pulled back in the forces of
of amith are just kind of waiting to
find out what their orders are going to
be
essentially like like what do we do now
and so essentially the the helmet is is
pulled off of apocalypse
saturnine restructures it and turns it
into a staff which is actually really
really really cool and then from there
it's kind of like okay
so like now that this contest is
basically done did i want a show
of good faith right i want to show of
good faith that you guys are not going
to wage war against each other again and
when the question is what's this show of
good faith she's like i want a mutant
from kokoa
to go to a rocco and i want a mutant
from morocco to go to cocoa that's what
i that's what i require
that's what i ask now with the carrot
with apocalypse uh basically
he ends up going with the iraq forces
right he ends up joining a rocco now
this does not mean that marvel's getting
rid of apocalypse if anything they're
probably just kind of keeping him on the
back burner for a little while because
in reality
this whole exoswords event was a story
about apocalypse
that's basically all this was it was
just a story about apocalypse but when
the questions asked who
basically speaks for kakoa who from
kokoa is going to demand somebody from
morocco
come to their come to their location
apocalypse says as the only member
really the highest ranking member of the
quiet council here
i will speak for percoa and the person
that i choose from morocco
to come to kokoa is the entire orocco
nation the entire island itself
right i want the island of morocco and
that's true remember morocco
is a sentient island and it was one half
of kokoa when they were okara right
that's the whole idea
and they were split in the in the sense
of like all these forces showing up in
the first place and apocalypse was
basically the one that did it he's
reuniting
the the island of of kokoa with the
rocco
recreating okara but he's doing it at
the sacrifice of himself
he is leading with his forces and it's
one of these cool things because what it
does
is it transforms the character of
apocalypse it takes him away from this
guy who's just like we're just gonna
destroy stuff and test the people who
are you know the most fit to make sure
they're they're actually fit you know
and just kind of be a dick from time to
time you know and and you know
and transforming from like that guy into
i am basically sacrificing my place on
the quiet council so i can be with my
wife and my kids right
it makes him a tragic hero and it's
amazing it's absolutely amazing that's
why stories like this are so cool
because jonathan hickman is so good at
changing up the entirety of characters
and so what you get here is a little bit
of an epilogue and i'm not going to
spoil
too much here because i believe this is
going to go into what is it though the
reign of x and like and oh
okay i'll i'll throw this out there it
looks like
jim jasper's is going to kind of seize
control right like it's going to focus
on jim jasper's
kind of rising to control and then who
knows what's going to happen right who
who hasn't had it because here's
something i want to make clear
to you guys saturnine was bound by magic
right she's bound by the limits of magic
so there's only so much you can do there
she's bound by like the limits of fate
and all that kind of stuff when it comes
to other world it's all kinds of
tradition fade all
pomp and circumstance all that kind of
stuff jim jaspers is a crazy guy
with the ability to manipulate up to you
know everything up to you and including
the multiverse right this guy is just a
as on a whole nother level right like
jim jasper's is ridiculous now
like jim jasper's if he's anything like
the way he was before
but has more fine-tuned control over his
powers then they've probably been
expanded right and if they've been
expanded if jim let me let me put it
this way if jim
jasper's weakness that he has to have a
reality to manipulate
in order to you know be be at his
absolute peak if that weakness is
removed
jim jasper's is right up there with like
the living tribunal if it's
if that's removed i'm not saying it is
but if that's removed jim jasper's is
well beyond the marquee of death and
matthew malloy and protege and all those
guys he's right up there with a living
tribunal if not between the living
tribunal and the one above all right
there's no limit to what he can do
that's a big if and we don't even have
any idea what they're going to do with
this character right so don't take this
as an absolute truth i'm not saying that
it is
but it's kind of bonkers right it's kind
of crazy because when when the dust
settles and everything
saturnine really kind of retakes her
place as the omniversal magistrix and
she got
pretty much everything she wanted the
reformation of the captain britain corps
the one person she didn't get was brian
braddock you know she of course wanted
him more than anybody else but
in essence the entire omniversal
development court has been restored
she's back to being the omniversal
magistrates and the captain britain core
has been returned that's
one of the reasons why i wanted to cover
the uh the original mad jim jasper story
all that stuff is coming back right all
that stuff is basically back to the way
it was before so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end uh i loved exo's swords i love the
extra swords event it was so good but if
you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob for if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you